Todos lo hacen con el propósito de salvar vidas.
Cuando mi propio padre se desplomó hace unos años
de un ataque al corazón, uno de los primeros voluntarios
en llegar a salvar a mi padre
fue uno de esos voluntarios musulmanes de Jerusalén Oriental
que formó parte del primer grupo que se unió a Hatzalah.
Y él salvó a mi padre.
¿Se imaginan cómo me sentí en aquel momento?
Cuando fundé esta organización, tenía 17 años.
Nunca imaginé que un día daría una charla en TEDMED.
Entonces ni siquiera sabía lo que era TEDMED.
No creo que existiera, pero nunca imaginé,
nunca imaginé que fuera a llegar a todas partes,
se va a difundir,
y el año pasado comenzamos en Panamá y Brasil.
Solo necesito un socio que sea un poco meshugenah como yo,
entusiasmado por salvar vidas, y deseando hacerlo.
Y de hecho voy a empezar en India dentro de muy poco
con un amigo que conocí en Harvard hace poco tiempo.
De hecho Hatzalah se fundó en Brooklyn por un judío jasídico,
años antes que nosotros en Williamsburg,
y ahora está dispersa por toda la comunidad judía de Nueva York,
y hasta en Australia y en México y en muchas otras comunidades judías.
Pero se podría extender a todas partes.
Es muy fácil de adoptar.
Uds. vieron a aquellos voluntarios en Nueva York
salvando vidas en el World Trade Center.
Solo en el año pasado tratamos en Israel 207.000 personas.
De ellas, 42.000 eran situaciones de vida o muerte.
Y nosotros marcamos la diferencia.
Supongo que uno podría llamarlo una multitud relámpago salvavidas,
y funciona.
Al mirar a mi alrededor, aquí,
veo mucha gente que dedicaría el esfuerzo necesario,
dedicaría la energía necesaria para salvar a otros,
sin importarles quienes son, sin importarles de qué religión,
sin importarles quienes son o de dónde vienen.
Todos queremos ser héroes.
Solo necesitamos una buena idea, motivación
y un montón de audacia,
y así podríamos salvar a millones de personas
que de otra manera no se salvarían.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)